ضمن موجه التسريح المستمره في تويتر غادرت
موظفه كان يطلق عليها الموظفه المتفانيه
كونها تعمل كثيرا لدرجه النوم في المكتب
ذكرت صحيفه الدائمه الى البريطانيه ان
الطرد شمل مديره اداره المنتجات او
الموظفه المتفانيه علما بانها قاده اطلاق
خدمه علامه التوثيق الزرقاء المدفوعه
الثمن في بدايه عهد ايلون ماسك وكتبت
الموظفه المتفانيه في تغريده ان اسوا شيء
حدث لها وهي تعمل على تطوير تويتر هو ان
تفاؤلها وعملها الجاد كان خطا
يعني اكيد في حدود للتفاني والعطاء في
العمل يعني تعملي ولكن في كمان الانسان
مصلحته في الموضوع لانه في كل بيئه عمل
هناك نموذج لموظف متفاني ولكن سؤال هل
العمل الكثير ياتي دائما بمكافاه للموظف
على فكره الدراسه وجدت ان الكثير من العمل
مكافاته تكون عموما المزيد من العمل مثلا
كمان في مصطلحات كثيره مفهوم ورك هارد
سمارت لكن المطلوب هو ثاني
يعني زي ما حكيت ذكي توازن